we're asked to solve the log of x plus
log of 3 is equal to 2 log of 4 minus
log of 2. so let me just rewrite it so
we have the log of x
plus the log of 3
is equal to 2 times the log of 4
minus
the log of 2 or the logarithm of 2. and
just as a reminder whenever you see a
logarithm written without a base the
implicit base is 10. so we could write
10 here 10 here 10 here and 10 here but
for the rest of the this example i'll
just skip writing the 10 just because
it'll save a little bit time but
remember this literally means log base
10. so this expression right over here
is the power i have to raise 10 to to
get x the power i have to raise 10 2 to
get 3. now that out of the way let's see
what logarithm properties we can use so
we know if we and these are all the same
base we know that if we have log base a
of b
plus log
base a of c that this is the same thing
as log
base a of b c
and we also know so let me write all the
logarithm properties that we know over
here we also know that if we have a
logarithm
a log
let me write it this way actually if i
have b
times the log base a of c this is equal
to log
base a of c to the b power and we also
know and this is derived really straight
from both of these is that if i have log
base a of b
minus log base a of c that this is equal
to the log base a of b
over c and this is really straight
derived from these two right over here
now with that out of the way let's see
what we can apply
so right over here we have all the logs
of the same base and we have logarithm
of x plus logarithm of 3. so by this
property right over here the sum of
logarithms with the same base this is
going to be equal to log
base 3 sorry log base 10 so i'll just
won't even well i'll write it here log
base 10 of 3 times x of 3 x
then based on
this property right over here this thing
can be rewritten let me say so this is
going to be equal to this thing can be
written as log
base 10
log base 10 of 4 to the second power
of 4 to the second power which is really
just 16.
so this is just going to be 16 and then
we still have
minus
logarithm base 10 of 2.
and now using this last property we know
we have one logarithm minus another
logarithm this is going to be equal to
log
base 10 of 16 over 2
right 16 divided by 2 which is the same
thing as
8. so the right hand side simplifies to
log base 10 of 8. the left-hand side is
log base 10 of 3x
so if 10 10 to some power is going to be
equal to 3x and 10 to the same power is
going to be equal to 8 so 3x must be
equal to 8. 3x must be equal to 8.
3x is equal to
eight
and then
we can divide both sides by three divide
both sides by three you get x is equal
to
eight over three one way this little
step here i said look 10 to the this is
an exponent if i raise 10 to this
exponent i get 3x 10 to this exponent i
get 8. so 8 and 3x must be the same
thing one other way you could have
thought about this is let's take 10 to
this power on both sides so you could
say 10
10 to this power and then 10 to this
power over here if i raise 10 to the
power that i need to raise 10 to to get
the 3x well i'm just going to get 3x if
i raise 10 to the power then i need to
raise 10 to to get 8 i'm just going to
get 8. so once again you got the 3x is
equal to 8 and then you can simplify you
get x is equal to 8 thirds